GILBERT STRANG: OK.
Two equations, the question of
stability for two equations,
stability around
a critical point.
OK.
So the idea will
be to linearize,
to look very near that
critical point, that point.
But now we're in two dimensions.
So that's a little more to do.
So here's the general picture,
and then here is an example.
So here's the general setup.
We have an equation
for the changes in y.
But z is involved.
And we have an equation for
the rate of change of z.
But y is involved.
So they're coupled together.
It's that coupling
that's going to be new.
So what's a critical point?
Critical point is when those
right-hand sides are 0.
Because then y and
z are both constant.
So they stay at that point.
Wherever they are at this
critical point is steady state.
They stay steady.
They stay at that
constant value.
So we want that to be 0.
And we want this to be 0.
We have two
equations, f equals 0,
and g equals 0, two equations.
But we have two
unknowns, y and z.
So we expect some solutions.
And each solution has to
be looked at separately.
Each solution is
a critical point.
It's like well, you could
think of a golf course,
with a surface going up.
So critical points will be
points where the maximum point
maybe, or the minimum
point, or we'll
see something called
a saddle point.
Actually, let's do the example.
The example is a famous one.
Predator-prey it's known as.
Predator like foxes,
prey like rabbits.
So the foxes eat the rabbits.
And the question is, what
are the steady states where
foxes' and rabbits'
constant values could stay?
So here this is the equation
for what happens to the prey.
So if the rabbits are left
alone, the prey is the rabbits.
If they're left alone they
multiply, plenty of grass.
Go for it.
But if there are foxes, and
z counts the number of foxes,
then foxes eat, shall
I say, those rabbits.
And we lose rabbits.
So we see that
with a minus sign.
And the amount of
preying that goes on
is proportional to
the number of foxes
times the number of rabbits.
Because that gives the
number of possible meetings.
And what about the
foxes, the predator?
The predator increases.
So this is from
encountering the rabbits.
That tends to make the
number of predators increase.
But if there were no rabbits,
the foxes don't eat grass.
They're out of luck,
and they decay.
So I see a minus z there.
So you see the pattern?
So starting from 0
and 0, at that point,
so I've defined critical points.
So there's my f.
And that should be 0.
And there is my g,
and that should be 0.
And it turns out there are
just two possibilities.
This is one.
If y and z are both 0, then
certainly I would get 0's.
So that's like starting with
a very small number of foxes
and rabbits.
Or if y is 1 and z equal 1,
do you see that that would be,
they would be in
perfect balance?
If y is 1, and z is 1,
then that's 0 and that's 0.
So the equation is satisfied.
We can stay at-- y can stay
at 1, and z can stay at 1.
It's a steady state.
And the question is, is that
steady state where rabbits
are staying--
their population is
staying at 1, because
they're eating grass, good.
But they're getting
eaten by the foxes, bad.
And those two balance, and
give a rate of change of zero.
And the foxes similarly, the
foxes get a positive push
from eating rabbits.
But natural causes
cut them back.
And they balance
at z equal to 1.
OK.
So what I have to
do is linearize.
And that's the real
point of the lecture.
That's the real point
for linear-- how
do linearize for two functions?
And how do you linearize
for these two functions?
So let me-- I have to write
the general formula first,
so you'll see it.
And then I'll apply it
to those two functions.
OK.
So here is the
idea of linearize.
So I'm linearizing.
So my first function is whatever
its value is at this point,
it's like a tangent line.
But now I've got
two derivatives.
Because the function
depends on two variables.
So I have a y minus
capital Y, times now I
have to do partial derivative.
So that's the slope in the
y direction, multiplied
by the movement.
And then similar term, z minus
capital Z times the movement
in the z direction.
And I have to,
because I stopped,
this is the linear
part of the function.
I have to put an
approximate symbol.
Because I've ignored
higher derivatives.
And of course this is 0.
So that's why we have
linear in y and linear in z,
times some numbers, the slopes.
But we have two more slopes.
Because we have another
function g of y and z.
And that again will
just be approximately
g at the critical point, which
is 0 plus y minus capital Y,
times dg dy plus z minus
capital Z times dg dz.
So altogether, the linear
stuff and four numbers,
the derivatives of f in
the y and z directions,
the derivatives of g in
the y and the z directions.
OK.
Now we had an example going.
Let me bring that
example down again.
There was my f.
There was my g.
Can easily find those
partial derivatives.
So let me do it.
So the partial derivative with
respect to y will be 1 minus z,
z held constant for
that partial derivative.
And the partial derivative with
respect to z will be minus y.
Let me write all
those things down.
So here is in the example.
So can I create a
little matrix, df dy?
It's the nice way, if I've
got four things, 2 by 2 matrix
is great.
df, dz; that number,
dg, dy; and dg dz.
You could say this is the
first derivative matrix.
It's the matrix of
first derivatives
and it's always named after
Jacobi who studied these first.
So it's called the
Jacobian matrix.
Maybe I'll put his name to
give him credit, Jacobi.
And the matrix is
the Jacobian matrix.
And its determinant
is important.
It's a very important matrix,
important in economics.
We're doing things--
I'm speaking here
about predator-prey, little
animals running around.
But serious stuff
is the economy.
Is the economy stable?
If it's a running along
at some steady state
and we move it a
little bit, does it
return to that steady
state, or does it
get totally out of hand?
So there is the Jacobian matrix.
And what are those derivatives?
Remember again, what functions.
There's my functions.
So the y derivative
is 1 minus z.
And the z derivative is minus y.
The y derivative is z, and
the z derivative is y minus 1.
Is that all right?
This is what we need to
know from the functions.
I've forgotten the functions
in the board that went up.
Here are their derivatives.
Now that's my Jacobian matrix.
That's my matrix of
the-- that matrix
has these four coefficients,
those four numbers.
And really, so
the linearization,
let me call that matrix.
I should call it J for Jacobian.
I will call it J for Jacobian.
OK.
That's the Jacobian matrix.
So then my approximate--
what's my linearized equation?
My linearized equation is the
time derivative of y and z.
So this left-hand side
is just dy dt, and dz dt.
So I'm using vector
notations, putting y
and z together, instead of
separately, no big deal.
So then I have this matrix
J, this 2 by 2 matrix,
times you notice here
is a y minus capital Y
and a z minus capital Z. There
is the linearized problem.
Linearized because
this is constant,
and this is linear, single y,
single z, and we have a matrix
J.
So I have to find-- so
now my little job is
find the critical points.
I've got everything ready.
I have to find the
critical points.
Now remember, the critical
points are where f and g are 0.
And let me remember
what those are.
So there is the f.
There's the g.
One critical point was that one.
Everything is 0.
Another critical
point is that one.
Again, everything is 0.
So I have two critical
points, two Jacobian matrices,
one at the first point,
one at the second point.
So what are those matrices?
At y and z equals 0, I have
the matrix-- I'll put it here,
and then I'll copy it.
If y and z are 0, I have a 1
and a 0 and a 0 and a minus 1.
I just took y and z to be 0.
That was the first
critical point.
The second critical point
gives me the Jacobian
at that second point.
The second point
was when z was 1.
So that's 0 now.
And y was 1, so that's minus 1.
z is a 1, y minus 1, y is a 1.
So that's a 0.
That's the second Jacobian.
So we're seeing something
interesting here.
We're seeing how 2
by 2 matrices will
work by really nice
examples, 1, 0, minus 1.
What's that telling me?
That's telling me
that the rabbits grow.
Because the rabbits
are the first, the y.
And the foxes decay.
And that's what's happening
when the two populations are
really small.
When the two populations
are really small,
multiplying them together
is extremely small.
So when the two populations
are really small,
forget the eating.
There aren't enough
people around, enough
foxes and rabbits around
to make a decent meal.
So I just have dy dt equal y.
Rabbits are growing
from eating grass.
dz dt is minus z, foxes are
decaying from natural causes.
So that's what kind of a
stationary point will 0, 0 be?
Rabbits are growing.
It's an unstable point.
We're leaving at 0, 0.
Rabbits are increasing.
Now how about the second point?
The second point was
when they were both 1.
when they're both 1, then we
got this as the Jacobian matrix.
Oh, this is the interesting one.
Can I just stay with
this one to finish?
So I'm interested
in the-- and I'll
put these facts on a new board.
So again, y prime
dy dt is y minus yz.
z prime is yz, rabbits are
getting eaten, minus z.
And I'm interested in the
point y equal 1, z equal 1.
And my matrix of this
is the Jacobian matrix.
The Jacobian matrix
had the derivatives,
which were 1 minus z, minus y.
The y derivative of that is z.
The z derivative is y minus 1.
And at this point y and z are 1.
So that became 0,
minus 1, 1 and 0.
And what kind of a
problem do I have here?
So my linearized
equation, so linearized,
linearized around the point 1,1.
My equation is y
minus 1 prime, sorry.
It's the distance to
the critical points.
the derivative of y minus
1 is, I see here a minus 1.
I see a minus z minus 1.
And here a plus y minus 1.
You've got to understand this
pair of linearized equations.
If I use some other variable,
the derivative of the first guy
is minus the second.
The derivative of the second
guy is plus the first.
What will happen?
Initially if I'm a little
bit-- if I have extra foxes,
the rabbit population will drop.
The rabbit population--
this will be negative.
If z, the number of foxes,
is a little higher than 1,
then the rabbit
population drops.
And when the rabbit population
drops, z starts dropping.
As z starts dropping below
1, the rabbit population
starts increasing.
I get, what shall we
say, sort of exchange
of rabbits and
foxes, oscillation
between rabbits and foxes?
So this is the--
right in the center
there, that would be the point
where y is 1 and z equal 1,
the critical point.
And if I start out with
some extra rabbits,
then the number of
rabbits will drop.
Because foxes are eating them.
The number of foxes
will increase.
I'll go up.
So there I have a little
bit later, I have foxes now,
but no rabbits to eat.
So the foxes start
dropping, and what happens?
I think, yeah.
The number of rabbit
starts increasing.
And this is what happens.
I'll go around and
around in a circle.
If you remember the pictures of
the paths for 2 by 2 equations,
there were saddle points.
That's what this is.
y equals 0, z equals
0 was a saddle point.
So no, it's a saddle.
And what I'm discovering
now for y equal 1
is an oscillation between
foxes and rabbits.
So again, I could say
it'll be our center that
was the very special picture
where it didn't spiral out.
It didn't spiral in.
The special numbers,
the eigenvalues
of that matrix
are-- well, better
leave eigenvalues
for the future.
Because they happen to
be i and minus i here.
It's motion in a circle.
It comes from this,
the equation here.
Motion in a circle as in y
double prime plus y equals 0.
That's motion in a circle.
And that's what we've got.
So this is a center.
Now what about-- do I
call a center stable?
Not quite, because the rabbits
and foxes don't approach 1.
They stay on a circle around 1.
Either I've got extra
rabbits or extra foxes.
But the total
energy or the total
stays a constant on that circle.
And I would call that
neutrally neutral.
Neutral stability, because
it doesn't blow up.
I don't leave the area around.
I stay close to
the critical point.
But I don't approach it either.
OK.
So that's a case where we
could see the stability, based
on the linearization.
OK.
One more example to
come in another lecture.
Thanks.